харківщина 47 кілометрів до лінії фронту
у цій зарослі бур’яном місцевості не
просто впізнати село довгеньке унаслідок
російських обстрілів тут не залишилося
жодної вцілілої хати та посеред руїн з
одного з подвір'їв доноситься рев
єдиного робочого трактора
я вам скажу
один з 9 постійних жителів се
ла тут дві школи було дві школи садять
клуб здоровий
Та ну все було у нас було абсолютно
Ну тепер не буде нічого перед тим як
показ його рідним селом Ігор з радістю
демонструє дб та єдине що його тут
втішає перший врожай воєнного часу на
своєму городі моя
проблема щоб виростити немає нужно Тока
разминировать Якби хтось помог
разминировать
було б проще Та ну ми не були на всіх
тут огородах потому что я ж кажу це був
передок оттуда вона вступление втягував
а потом виносив її нельзя не крутить не
крутить потому що хтось знав як воно там
ну
я щось огород це один огород і ще в мене
5 огорода я разминировал сам ходив
село довгеньке у березні торік опинилося
на лінії оборони шляху до Слов'янська
щоденно тут велися запеклі Танкові бої
просто посеред вулиці а з квітня у хатах
місцевих оселилися російські окупанти
які тримали село під контролем аж до
вересня такого сценарію каже Ігор ніхто
не очікував ви просто не понімали що
делать Ізюм погода Взяли Ізюм погода
потом взяли Кам'янку а потом уже воно
сюда начало пролітать просто люди не
понімали люди були в надежді що щас все
буде нормально сейчас отоб'ють і все
такое Ну 12 человек
ждали ждали висиджували висиджували Ну
ми не батя три человека найшов
зайшов а вони всі троє там лежали вони
прильот був і воно наверное жахнули
з перших днів повномасштабного нападу РФ
на Україну староста села втік минулий
весни евакуювалася і більшість місцевих
наприкінці березня торік виїхали і
князеві але за півроку після звільнення
довгенького родина повернулася і застала
на своєму подвір'ї лише згарище
зерно конечно було
пшениці була 50 тонна семечки 30
не мільйончик лежала зерно це отсюдова
вже повитаскували честь тракторов
то комбайн згорів повністю
оце тут овцы жили вони не то що жили
вони тут кушали щоб не на вулиці ну одні
косточки ось поставили советс
Ну вони часто там по кущах валяють
шерсть ось Просто видно що це були
маррашки
Попри це все Ігор та його родина вірять
що зможуть самотужки відновити
господарство
щоб оце надо було Хоч щось сохранить
даже вот этот металлолом надо було тут
бути
прийняв рішення що надо оставатися та й
все
оскільки хата повністю зруйнована цієї
весни волонтери надали Ігорю його матері
та батькові тимчасовий дах над головою
ось цей модульний будинок щоправда тут
відсутні газ вода та електрика синок
сьогодні привіз помидорчики і молоко
А як він
працює
це просто
[музика]
Ну вона технічна вода з водою тут
проблема конечно
ось тут колодязь тут лежить насос
вставлений там внутри Вот это по трубі
моя качаємо
питну воду і продукти родина купує у
місті Ізюм за 23 кілометри звідси
електричну плитку та інші прилади
підключають до дизельного генератора
на свою чашку
68-річний батько Ігоря Анатолій князів
кається що колись вважав росіян братами
до яких пів села роками їздили на
заробітки
до братів раньше читали Ми нормально і я
молодці в Москві робив тепер Їх навіть
тільки перебити щоб до нас обійшли з
руїн що по собі лишили російські
окупанти родина знайшла дещо що
згодилося у побуті цю кухні де усі п'ють
чай Ігор з батьком самі побудували з
ящиків з підросійських градів до зими
князеві планують добудувати з них і нове
житло кілька кімнат над відновленою
котельнею
це все строїлось з нуля
ну це лестница на второе этаж Ну вона ще
не додела они ещё делать ніколи пока
делать це спальня я иногда тут сплю
Ну бо куда сок нам і проблема у перерві
між хатніми справами батько Ігоря
Анатолій Князєв прогулюється із собакою
та вівцями рідною вулицею І дивиться чи
не повернувся хтось до сусідських хат до
повномасштабної війни тут жилося 760
людей серед яких і багато етнічних
росіян каже чоловік Ну а тут володюха
що я казав що росіяни як їх одна сім'я
була раніше ну вони 40 год вже як тут
живуть А тепер вони тут на Україні вони
під Дніпром та утекли а родняв його в
Росії як оце буть йому з ними є вони
розбили йому хату на дорозі досі лежать
танкові снаряди
Віталька ти додому
лише в одній хаті застаємо господаря
Віталій теж виїжджав із довгенького і
повернувся минулої осені у нього немає
половини будинка та Попри це він
продовжує розводити у дворі кролів і
бджіл вони вас трогать не будуть
побила порозліталася Це ось знайшов
крапки
ось це один он і ще один
воздух даже свежий
Ну от ми сейчас мене сім'я в городі
мамка з донькою
Вони
приїжджають до них ну не то не той
воздух тут все равно на много Я ж коли
ще дихати дихати
як обгарадюся може коли
баранів ще Заведу
пасіку дальше сделай зараз
у селі більше Одна кілька місцевих які
повернулися додому загинули на власних
подвір'ях підірвалися на розтяжках або
мінах були в нас знайомий тут загинув
підірвалися хлопці вони приїхали теж так
як Ігор намагалися відбудовуватися бо
теж тут мали землю пішли хотіли мабуть
худобу свою знайти Може якось не знаю
пішли на розтяжці підірвалися Юлія з
чоловіком приїхали до свого дому аби
вивести звідси нову партію металобрухту
кажуть цим займається більшість тих хто
не може тут лишитися жити Це залізяча
останнє що можна продати усе інша цінне
серце майно перетворилося на попіл що у
нас тут було літня Кухня гараж два сараї
в нас було у нас коли перший приліт був
тут по каравану в нас якраз в той день
свиня поросилася в нас було 18 свиней
випустили два дорослих бика дві корови
курочки нутрії
кролики
собаки коти
все було
Ну так
звільнили вже так звільнили що можна
сказати
те яким село було колись розповідатимуть
онукам каже Ігор Князєв Ти вже Просто
ніхто не вернеться потому що я знаю вже
там і там в житті уїхали за границю ті
купили вже дом того вообще нема убила
Я думаю
уже не була остануться только хазяйство
то вийде вже
замінировано у села довгеньке є
потенціал сільськогосподарський кажуть
князеве нині найголовніше для родини
продати цьогорічний урожай
зрозумінованого городу і полагодити ще
придатні Трактори це шанс відродити
улюблену справу на рідній землі